mentally no matter what no matter how
much you're training that first two
miles your mind's gonna try to stop you
with everything it has even if you got
great momentum going your mind is going
to give you everything it has it's how
you stop once you get past that first
two miles you can kind of go
like it really opens up if you can keep
a pace it's all about just pacing your
breath keeping your heart rate under
control and just keeping a nice smooth
steady Pace be mindful of your where
your feet are landing and you can go out
there and do way more than you think you
can
and that's just this is just one thing
in life but running it sucks like a lot
of people said damn I can't [__] run
to you know whatever I feel like that
too kinda I feel like you know like
also but I put my mind to it and just
did it just to do it you know like my
sister-in-law is like why like at the
end of it when I [__] Frozen and
couldn't get up the bleachers and
couldn't sit down and [__] it's just
like it's just it's good to challenge
yourself now I know I can yeah